Next question, on Saturday, two weeks of Morganella my stools became brown instead of tan and I slightly more forward. I think this person was taking antibiotics for this.
However, in addition to my bloated belly, I began retaining fluid went from 112 pounds to 134 pounds now.
Firstly, it's not helped. I had two doses of over the counter, diuretic, diurex, but no relief. What is this from and what can I do?
Well, I wish I could just tell you right off the top of my head, but I am not that start.
All sorts of things. I mean, different things could be going on with the bloating.
First thing you think of with bloating, honestly, is smaller testable bacterial overgrowth.
So that's a possibility, even if you are taking it antibiotic.
So I would suggest number one, if you're taking any fiber or eating a lot of fiber or fiber rich foods or starches or sugars, try to eliminate that from your diet right off the bat.
Make sure you're taking HCl, make sure you're taking digestive enzymes to help call that down. The other thing that can really help with this is butary acid.
So like our tributarate, there's a lot of uteric acids on the market now. Those would be good to use.
I would even suggest some glutamine for a short period of time to call this down.
Again, getting doing another stool sample test. That's always good to test right see if there's anything else going on if there's other pathogens, anything else going on that would be another thing to look at.
But you know, with this information, you were just we don't have enough data really to know without doing some tests.
Also, with SIBO, you can't rule out the issue with issues with the with the brain got access. So very common with people with chronic got issues, it's a vagal nerve problem.
So remember, the vagus nerve, cranial nerve tend comes out of the membrane goes down to the spine. It, it, it, it, it, it is responsible for the autonomic function of the intestinal track.
You have a gut rate access type or type of activation and decrease activation of the vagal nerve.
It can, it can result in a decrease in motility which can lead to SIBO type things as well.
How do you stimulate the vagal nerve go back to our website and look up parasympathetic sympathetic and you'll see a whole bunch of parasympathetic stimulating things. You also see a downloadable PDF chart. This is also on the on the cancer course and stuff as well.
How to call the sympathetics. So remember, autonomic nervous system, you got the parasympathetics and the sympathetics. So you have to have that imbalance usually in these cases, it's a hyper sympathetic response because of the imbalance is from a hypo vagal response, the vagus nerve is the parasympathetic response.
So stimulating the vagus nerve. Look at that, download this chart, start doing as many of those exercises as possible as silly as they seem from the functional neurology perspective they can do real well. Hello, coffee enemas, number one trend for this again. So coffee enemas, number one, friend for vagal nerve stimulation do that as well.